[Applaus] diese e-fuels sind
ja offensichtlich fürs Klima
0 nützlich ich war wie will die FDP denn
den Klimawandel sonst bekämpfen sprachlich
herzlich willkommen zur fdp-kunde Kommunikation
und Lauterer nachhaltigkeitsversprechen für
deutsche Einwohner der Sprachschule für
Mitglieder und Freunde der FDP erwartet Sie
bald in Prominenz Booster Talkshow Auftritt
mit renitänden klimaaktivistinnen dann sind
Sie genau richtig in dieser Schulung bedenken
Sie Ihre Gegner warten mit einem gefährlichen
kommunikativen Trick auf der Wirklichkeit sie
schon sich nicht Überschwemmungen Dürren und
salzbrände für ihre Zwecke zum missbrauchen
die Realität ist also ihr größter Konkurrent
auf dem Marktplatz der Ideen deswegen drei
Beispiele wie sie mit den richtigen Worten
die Klimakrise einfach wegsprechen erstens sie
könnten natürlich sagen die Klimakatastrophe
ist eine Krise bei der Millionen von Menschen
vor allem im globalen Süden elendig verhungern
ertrinken und in der Hitze qualvoll sterben
werden oder aber Sie sagen der Klimawandel
ist einer der größten Herausforderungen in
unserer Zeit packen wir es richtig an kann
Klimaschutz aber auch zu einer unserer größ
die Chancen werden zweitens statt zum Beispiel
zu sagen als Klientelpartei die wir sind hat
die Automobilindustrie unsere Schaltknüppel
fest im Griff sagen sie lieber wir sind davon
überzeugt dass wir einen effektiven Klimaschutz
nur dann erreichen wenn wir auf Erfindergeist und
technologieoffenheit setzen streuen Sie überhaupt
technologieoffen gerne so oft wie möglich ein es
klingt schlau unternehmerisch liberal im besten
Sinne des Wortes und gleichzeitig zeichnet
es alle anderen apokalyptischen Langweiler
als verschlossen verengt miese Petrich die
möchten offenbar Internet aus Holz drittens
auf keinen Fall sollten Sie feststellen dass
die Klimakrise ein systemisches Problem ist
welches auch strukturelle Veränderungen erfordert
vermeiden Sie es auch die in die Verantwortung zu
nehmen die für die Klimakrise verantwortlich sind
vor allem wenn sie verantwortlich sind es ist
nicht Volker Wissing der die Klimaziele im Verkehr
nicht erreicht es sind die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
eben mobil sein wollen
perfekt im Geiste der FDP Freiheit ist wenn
jeder das Klima eigenverantwortlich zerstört
und nicht diese Ölindustrie ich wünsche
Ihnen mit unserem Sprachmodell Kunde und
unserem semantischen Greenwashing viel
Erfolg bei der nächsten Überschwemmung
im Aartal wenden sie dort doch direkt an
was sie hier gelernt haben versuchen Sie es
bei den Hausbesitzern beispielsweise statt eines
mitleidigen mein Gott ihr Haus ist ja vollkommen
zerstört eher mit einem fröhlichen sehen Sie
Umweltpolitik als Innovationsmotor abonniert
sich eines von den beiden Videos
hier angeschaut mir vollkommen
dass ich in den meisten mitspielen muss die
richtige Art ist für uns Werbung zu machen